[Music]
ultimately I want to make the point that
in such a world growth and equality are
not only they're not substitutes there
are strong complements so welcome to the
30th cause net Memorial Lecture
presented by the economic growth Center
I'm Rohini Pandey I'm a professor at the
Economics Department and director of AGC
the Kostas lecture is an annual lecture
on issues and economic development given
by prominent economic economists in
memory of Simon Simon Kuznets the famous
Belarusian American economist whose Ness
was not a Yale professor but he was
instrumental in founding EGC in 1934
Kuznets had launched the u.s. national
income statistics series the motivation
was to use data for policy the series
was issued to meet the need to describe
consistently and in detail the economic
toll taken by the Great Depression
post-world war ii as colonialism the big
question was what would drive economic
development in the poorer parts of the
world cuz that saw a reason for a Center
to do something that his home
institution were not able to do you to
use vivid data to describe development
and so he turned to Yale to set up the
Institute which is now known as eg C he
C was arguably the first Development
Research Center in a major u.s.
University that focused on using
quantitative methods to understand
economic development today as we gain
access to greater data and improve
computational power in estimation
methods economists are responding to
Kuznetsov of 1934 which was to say the
welfare of a nation can scarcely be
inferred from a measurement of national
income alone to look at broader measures
of inequality this broadening focus of
development research will be the theme
of Professor Goldberg's lecture tonight
and of the conference that she will lead
tomorrow when it comes to bridging
inequalities based on gender
it takes bold women to be willing to be
the first to enter space as previously
held by men
penny Goldberg is one such woman she was
the first female professor to be given
tenure by the Yale economic department
she was the first female editor in chief
of the American
review and as president-elect of the
chronometric Society for 2021 she will
be its first female president
more recently penny served as the only
the second ever female chief economist
of the World Bank after an Krueger who
also happened to be the only other woman
to have delivered the coarseness lecture
in his 30 year history Penny's research
takes on important questions and trade
and development
she studied large trade liberalisation
episodes in developing countries her
work has drawn out the contrasting
implications of trade reform in India
and Latin America for product markets
and inequality her most recent research
examines resurgence of protectionism in
the US and the interplay between
informality and trade liberalisation
many someone whose work I've admired for
a long time and she has been an
important role model for me and many
other women in the profession so this
year's yield celebrates the 50th
anniversary of the matriculation of
women and Yale College and 150th
anniversary of the first women's
students in the university
it seems particularly appropriate that
we welcome this pioneering woman to
deliver the 38 Kuznets maori lecture
please welcome professor goldberg hello
first of all Rohini thank you so much
for this very generous introduction I'm
very happy to be back for good now Yale
has been a wonderful home to me for many
years and I'm looking forward to
assuming that my academic duties but
today I'm going to talk still as chief
economist of the World Bank Group I have
three more days on my term and the
reason I mentioned that is not because
there's going to be any juicy gossip if
that's why you were here for I'm afraid
I'm going to disappoint you but because
when picking the topic for this lecture
I I did try to be consistent with the
theme of goodness research which as
Rohini mentioned was very much focused
on inequality and growth but but also I
wanted to build on my World Bank
experience for the past two years so I'm
going to draw on this and what this
means is I will start
with some preliminary thoughts about
perspective that one has from the chief
economist office of the World Bank what
I mean by that so so one advantage of
being at the World Bank is that one gets
exposed to what I would call the big
picture question questions in economics
and for the past few years there has
been an tendency to focus on smaller
questions at least in research and
economics questions that we can address
very well but the scope of them tends to
be more narrow perhaps many of you have
seen a very well-known lecture by one of
the Nobel Prize winners this year Esther
Duflo
she gave the ELA lecture a few years ago
when the title of the ELA lecture was
the economist as a plumber and there she
made a point that it's very important
for economists to get the details of
implementation of policy implementation
right because it doesn't matter how good
your policy is if you don't get the
details right the policy is going to
come to nothing it I I love this lecture
I'd very much believe in this message
and after being at the World Bank for a
year and a half I believe in this
message even more strongly than before
that said I think one should not forget
that in order to build a functional
building you need the plumber but you
also need the architect and the engineer
and and as much as I believe that some
of us should spend time on
implementation and plumbing I also think
some of us should also spend some time
on the big picture questions in
economics and trying to figure out how
everything fits together and when you're
in the world when you are forced to do
that all the time partly because you
interact with countries with finance
ministers with policy makers and they
really want more from you than how a
specific project will work they will
want to know what your vision for
development is which brings me to one of
the motivations of this lecture I'm
going to make the point that we are at a
point in time where we need a new vision
a new model for development I will
explain what I mean in a moment so I
think that was one very positive aspect
of being at the World Bank you're forced
to think about these questions the other
thing that's very different in the world
man
compared to academia is that you are
constantly forced to think in
cross-country terms and and as I'm sure
you all know cross-country regressions
have become an anathema in empirical
work in academics many people don't take
them seriously anymore but in the World
Bank this is often the foundation of
giving advice to countries so countries
will often come to you and say you are
the World Bank you've been to all these
countries you know what works in country
a can you tell us how we would apply it
to our own country so you are constantly
forced to think in this cross country
terms to run cross country regressions
in your head all the time but I actually
think that this is very productive it is
a good thing to do as long as you
understand the limitations of this and
and you don't use you don't confine
yourself to a straitjacket of an
aggression and pretend that you have you
know absolutely robust scientific
evidence so understand that because what
I'm going to talk about is going to
build on these observations in some
sense I'm going to employ some cross
country analysis and I'm going to rely a
lot on on correlations rather than clean
identification but I think some
correlations can be actually quite
informative so so I'll use this is not
going to be the standard academic talk
I'm going to use many pictures and
correlations to just just tell a story
so that's as I said I think that there
is there is a great demand among
policymakers these days for a new vision
for development it'll be more specific
in a moment at the same time there is
great demand especially among advanced
economies among industrialized countries
for more equality or less inequality so
the focus of policy in many countries in
the last few years has been on
inequality not on poverty poverty seems
almost a forgotten world outside the
World Bank and when
in the world banking in talks or or
seminars I made a point for more
equality I immediately got pushback from
countries from poorer countries that
asked does this mean you you give up on
growth we don't care about inequality
for us growth it's much more important
and what underlies this comment is this
very strongly held view among economies
that there is a trade-off between growth
and inequality and of course this
trade-off is to a certain extent based
on the famous goodness curve that
posited that there is a trade-off at
least in the early stages of development
there is a trade-off between growth and
inequality as an economy grows then
inequality Rises but eventually it
tapers off so I will have something to
say about that too so with that
introduction let me give you a more
specific roadmap for this talk I will
start by explaining what I mean by the
old model of development that was based
to a large extent on export land
industrialization this is a model
perhaps it has been not that influential
in academia but it was it was the
cornerstone of advice the World Bank or
the IMF and many other institutions
international institutions gave then I
will talk about the recent retreat from
globalization and multilateral is we've
experienced in the last few years and
that will make the point that this
retreat actually poses a challenge for
this old model and that also gives rise
to this need for a new vision for
development and regarding this new
vision there are various proposals that
are made fairly casually actually the
development world one of them is leap
frogging into the service sector
skipping the manufacturing stage another
one concerns urbanization like
development and finally what I really
want to talk about today is the idea
that if we transition to a world that's
more closed less open with less trade
with less globalization then domestic
markets become more important and if
domestic markets become more important
then a certain degree of equality may
become
an important precondition for growth so
ultimately I want to make the point that
in such a world growth and equality are
not only they're not substitutes there
are strong complements so when I make
this point of course it's it's the way I
express it it's very general and
open-ended so I will try to make it more
concrete by operationalizing this notion
of the domestic market and to do that
that's when you need a conceptual
framework so I will talk a little bit
about a theoretical framework that quant
can use to think about these issues and
then some empirical work that I've been
recently working on and present some
results and eventually as I said the
points I want to make and this will be
the conclusion in case you fall asleep
or you have to leave early for a small
country it's nearly impossible if not
completely impossible to eliminate
poverty if this country remains closed
so openness to trade is extremely
important so when we mean openness in
that context openness in these days
means more than trade it means deep
integration so a deep integration I mean
essentially measures that that makes
sure that whatever trade agreements you
have are enforceable but also measures
that that contribute to stronger capital
and labor flows between countries
alternatively if if you don't if you
don't have this this path that involves
more openness more trade and if you need
to focus on the domestic market larger
countries have it easier if you're India
you're going to have an easier time
growing because you can draw on the
domestic market but in such in such a in
such a setting it's important to to have
a certain degree of equality that we
support the emergence of a healthy
middle class so that the purchasing
power of this middle class can support
development so this is where where I'm
going with this and let me now be a
little more specific so as I said I will
start by explaining what the
old model of export-led
industrialization husband so what's this
model so this model is part of the
so-called Washington Consensus and you
know these terms have been have become
extremely controversial but actually if
you think about what the Washington
Consensus involved it involved a set of
many policies a set of policies many of
which actually are fairly reasonable
from an economists point of view three
of the of the most important pillars of
these Washington Consensus were
deregulation privatization and trade
liberalisation so embracing open
international markets and the idea there
was as follows so if we apply this model
to developing countries developing
countries are abundant in low-skill able
low wage labor so by by engaging in free
trade in open trade they can they can
utilize their comparative advantage and
this comparative advantage is most the
most utilized in basic manufacturing by
exporting to higher income countries a
lot of good things happen as I mentioned
they can utilize their comparative
advantage in addition they can tap into
the purchasing power of richer countries
if you are if you were China in the 80s
or Vietnam you know in the early 90s you
don't need to rely on a rich domestic
market to sell your products you can
rely on the richer consumers in the
United States or Europe you can of
course you can realize economies of
scale from selling to the global market
and and hence industrialize and finally
you can use all the export revenue to
finance investments in infrastructure or
human capital so investments that I'm
going to give you the foundations for
long run development and so this kind of
model were that has been applied to many
countries mostly in East Asia is
logically consistent you can see how the
various parts work by the way here I'm
presenting a verbal feature of these
models
international trade economies have spent
many years building models that that
formalized these ideas so the morning
has debuted at it logically consistent
it's a framework that we understand you
can disagree with it but once you have
the framework you know how to attack it
how to to take issue with some of these
assumptions but but I would say overall
it has been actually supported by the
casual observation at evidence and here
I'm thinking of course mostly of what
happened in East Asia and especially
China so let me give you you know the
story in a few pictures and as I said
I'm going to rely here on correlations
so you're not going to see any
regressions claiming identification the
the modern era so post-world War two and
this starts in 1827 ok and on that
vertical axis our exports global exports
as percentage of GDP so you can see you
know there is some variations in this
percentage over time here that that 1945
and after 1945 so after World War 2
exports start rising very fast these
here this is the period of what people
call the hyper globalization when
exports when trade starts growing very
fast as percentage of GDP and this is
partly powered by the emergence of
global value chains in the emergence of
fragmentation in production so this is a
global phenomenon it's not driven by
specific countries so here you can see
essentially the same picture so here
fortunately the numbers came out and you
can see it for the world as a whole this
is essentially the previous graph but
you can also see it for selected
countries and what's interesting here
I'm going to point out is if you look at
the USA this is the blue line here you
see a trend upwards but for the US this
trend is not that pronounced and the
reason part of the reason is the u.s. is
already a very large rich country so
trade is important for the US but it's
not as important for the US as it is for
countries that are still poor it's of
course very important for China this is
China and many people say
hyperglobalisation the increasing trade
is driven by China China is clearly an
important part of the story but it's not
just China it's it's many other
countries for example it's India so I'm
here I put some of the biggest countries
but you can see it also more clearly in
this graph that shows the composition of
world exports by income groups and this
is based on on on a classification that
the World Bank uses the World Bank makes
a distinction between high-income
countries and then between upper-middle
income lower middle-income and
low-income countries and this
classification here is based on 1987 so
it's time invariant so for example China
was a low income country in 87 by now
it's upper middle income but for the
purpose of this graph China will always
appear in the low income category so you
can see in 85 if we take countries other
than the high income countries
cumulatively they accounted for about
13% of total exports world exports and
that makes sense you know most of the
economic activity comes from the rich
countries as you would expect
so by 2015 if you take you know the
cumulative share of upper middle income
lower middle-income and low-income
countries is about 33% so it has
increased dramatically and in that part
is driven to a very large extent by
China but again it's not only China many
other developing countries have
participated in this phenomenon now what
has this done for poverty and for
poverty across the world at the same
time we had a very sharp reduction in
global poverty and global inequality
across the world and of course you're
going to say that there are many factors
that drove this decrease it's not just
trade and perhaps the most important one
was speaks you know you cannot have
growth and prosperity and poverty
reduction unless you have peace and
that's certainly true but what I will
also make the point that that trade has
played an important role and this is not
something that you
show through a regression that is going
to address all concerns you may have
regarding identification but I do think
that if we take the evidence that has
been accumulated over the years and by
that I mean regressions I mean anecdotal
evidence at anecdotal accounts I mean
that many case studies that actually my
predecessor or the World Bank and Kruger
conducted 30 years ago mostly on East
Asia and Southeast Asia
then all these all these studies
together a tell the story of trade
contributing to growth in poverty
reduction not to mention the recent
experience the relatively recent
experience of China and in Vietnam and
Korea and and this story is also
reflected in a series of books so I will
mention a few here detune the Great
Escape
this is a book that's extremely critical
of the World Bank and but but it does
make the point that that globalization
has contributed very significantly to
the Great Escape and the Great Escape is
the great escape from poverty there is
the World Bank report one development
report from 2006 and that report also
made the point a very important point at
that time that if we think about
inequality not within borders but
globally about the the difference the
discrepancy between the well-being of
the globally rich and the globally poor
this has been dramatically dramatically
reduced
post-world War two and one of the
persons who worked on that World
Development Report was actually Branko
Milanovic who after he left the World
Bank he actually worked on the book of
his book global inequality so the book
that became a best-seller and it made
him truly famous and that's again a book
that makes this point that that global
inequality by global inequality you
could be in some sense you can take that
as a synonym for poverty has been
reduced dramatically post-world War two
and again globalization has played a
very important role in all this and that
rate is also the question that
actually a question that that Bronco
Branko Milanovic explicitly asks in his
book whether there is actually a
trade-off between global inequality and
within country inequality so one of his
hypothesis is that this reduction in
global inequality has happened at the
expand at the expense of an increase in
domestic inequality some more pictures
that that tell this story and I think
these are very telling this is this is
the very famous elephant curve and this
elephant so the blue part comes from
Bronco from actually and you know that
they actually the green part was later
added by by carolyn Freund and so what
is elephant so I will call this the old
elephant curve because it has been
updated and I'll show you in a moment
how but what this elephant axis you have
the percentiles of the global income
distribution so this is taking the
world's population putting it together
and then looking at the percentiles of
this distribution and then on the
vertical axis you have the income growth
rate and percentage term this is per
capita income and you know the striking
and this is all between 88 and 2008 okay
so this is precisely this period
includes precisely the period of the
hyperglobalisation it is during this
period where you see the fastest growth
in these percentiles these are actually
the world's poor so according to that
figure it's mostly the world's poor that
have benefited the most from growth of
course the very rich also benefit a lot
so the very top 1% but but this is the
main message of this curve was that
poverty that the growth was such that
actually poverty declined until declined
very sharply now as I said this curve
was updated with very different data we
recently by a number but by a team of
researchers three of whom in that team
include you know the famous trio size P
Katie and sook one of Berkeley and the
reason I mention that is because this
this curve uses different data so it
uses tax income tax data so the same day
that they have used in their other work
to demonstrate that it's the top 1% has
benefited the most from you know from
recent from recent economic changes and
this curve does not look like an
elephant anymore it looks more like a
dragon I think but what it shows very
clearly is that you have a
disproportionate increase in well-being
at the top one percent so here you know
the the growth in the top 1% that
captured a very large share of total
growth however you know it also makes
very clear the point that that many have
made that it's the middle class in the
US and Western Europe that gets squeezed
ok so these are the people who benefit
the least but still you know you see
that they're really poor in the world
still benefit from growth so so the
message that the recent economic trends
have benefited the poor I think remains
still valid even if you use this updated
curve that paints a much less rosy
picture about what growth does for the
poor and by the way if you if you wonder
what the source of the differences
between the two curves are that there
are many in my view the main the main
issue is that these curve is based on
tax data that captured the very top of
the distribution the other curve that I
showed you is based on survey data and
there you always have the problem that
the top incomes are not captured by the
surveys but again my point here is that
that any way you put it it's very hard
to deny the message that poverty has
very sharply declined and it is also
reflected in this picture here which
which comes from World Bank estimates of
poverty so what this shows is what has
happened to poverty to the head count to
the poverty headcount over time by
different regions and so first if you
look at the total you know you see that
the total has we are here now the total
has declined so the number of poor has
declined this is the projection
according to the World Bank what is
likely to happen by 2030 one interesting
aspect of this graph is actually that
it's broken down by different regions in
the classifications of the regions again
reflects the World Bank classification
so there's some interesting patterns
here and one pattern is let me point out
this this part the the brown one
this is East Asia in East Asian you can
you can see that poverty has been almost
eliminated this part that you can hardly
see reddish is Europe and Central Asia
and again in these parts of the world
poverty has been eliminated by the way I
forgot to mention poverty here is
defined as living on less than one point
nine dollars per day so it's a very low
bar for poverty okay so these people are
really extremely poor it's a very modest
criterion but nevertheless even using
this criterion we see that if you look
at at a different region if you look at
Africa this is the yellow part here the
picture is much much less rosy not only
has poverty no declined poverty has
increased enough in sub-saharan Africa
and in fact it's projected to to
increase even more and the same actually
applies to this part that again you can
hardly see it because that the region is
very small this is Menace so this is
Middle East and North Africa again
poverty is increasing there so poverty
has declined in many parts of the world
it remains very high in Africa and the
Middle East and in fact there it's
increasing so this is you know in terms
of you know in terms of background of
what has happened to poverty
now the second point I want to make is
that I don't know if I have managed to
convince you that globalization was part
of the story it's not the entire part
there are many other things that
happened at the same time but but but we
do see the fastest poverty reductions in
precisely those parts of the world that
embraced openness and again East Asia
comes immediately to mind especially
China but that said is what we have
experienced since 2008 is a slowdown in
trade so this slowdown started after the
financial crisis so after during a
financial crisis trade collapsed
completely after the financial crisis it
started growing back but again at a very
slow pace and it never quite gained its
previous momentum and some some people
have attributed this slowdown to a
secular slowdown what I mean by that is
the following so to a certain extent
trade was fueled by this emergence of
global value chains and they would have
global value chains partly because it
became technologically possible to
fragment production and many thought at
some point fragmentation may have run
its course if you if you take a car you
can split it into parts and components
and you can trade those back and forth
but eventually you run out of parts to
split right you go down to the screws
and you know the nuts and bolts
eventually there is no you kind of
fragment anymore so there's some who
have thought who thought that this may
be part of the story and in fact the one
thing you see is if you look at global
value chains trade so it peaked around
2010 and then it started going down as a
percentage of trade so again with global
volume change this is the hyper
globalization you see this very fast
growth during that time ah in my view
this is this there is very little
evidence to support this view there is
something else that has been going on
mostly in very recent years so in the
last five years and this is the the very
strong policy backlash so the backlash
against globalization and I think this
this presents a much more serious threat
to trade and openness and globalization
in general so what do I mean by these so
first there has been a revolt of the
public in many developed primarily
countries against free trade and
immigration and this is not specific to
a particular country or to a particular
party we seen in the United States but
if there is one issue where there is
bipartisan support for is the the
opposition to free trade you can be
Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders and they
both they both advocate protection is in
even more important than the terrace in
the return to protectionism has been
what the US has been doing to the World
Trade Organization so the World Trade
Organization is by now defunct due to
the United States policies in the UK we
have had break seed which again is a
retreat from multilateralism I already
mentioned the World Trade Organization
the WTO in addition you know despite
this generally held view that the trade
is free there has been uneven
liberalisation of agricultural trade
agricultural trade is still very
protected and this is something that's a
very big issue for developing countries
the services trade remains highly
restricted and finally there are arising
behind what people call behind the
border measures and other distortions
these are all on the rise so if you take
all this together I think it's fair to
say that there has been a retreat from
globalization and let me show you you
know again some pictures what the trends
are so this shows what has happened to
trade policy not trade between 1948 and
2016 and I often use this graph to make
the point the despite this again broadly
held view that that the globalization
has been mostly a technological
phenomenon fuelled by locally
and transportation costs I want to make
the point that trade policy policy has
been important one way you see that is
by seeing what happened to Retel - Tariq
so these are tariffs applied types in
developing countries so these types have
been going down more importantly if you
look at membership in the World Trade
Organization
so this membership has gone up steadily
and especially what was really important
is that the word the World Trade
Organization included many developing
countries and perhaps even more
importantly we've had many regional
trade agreements so these blue bars show
the increase in regional trade
agreements so if you take all these
measures together lower tariffs increase
participation in World Trade
Organization and regional trade
agreements they show they until 2016
they show that a trend towards more
integration so that is to be contrasted
with with what has happened post 2016 so
this is the new policy environment so
this is the percentage of import that's
covered by tariffs it's still a very
small one so this is for the United
States about 12% of 2018 by now it's
actually higher China Mexico in the EU
you know you may think this is still a
very low percentage but what's important
is that it has risen relative to what it
was five years ago and it's it's also
accompanied by certain rhetoric that
makes the future of trade very uncertain
another you know telling graph is this
one so it shows how many new trade
agreements were formed in recent years
by 2018 this number can't drop
dramatically this is partly due to the
fact that there is enormous uncertainty
regarding the future of trade relations
so the world is becoming much more
closed in my view and and this is
something that I would not have said
about a year ago when trade tensions
first arose my view was that perhaps
this was just talk
negotiation but we have to wait and see
what happens but I think after after two
years of of seeing what has happened
across the world I do think we we are in
a new regime where trade tensions are
going to be the new normal so this is
what the trade side and the policy side
so I think in such an environment
manure a developing country if you're a
developing country that has not yet
benefited from trade with the US or
Europe if you are a small country in
Africa if you're Kenya or if you are
Ghana I don't think you can be sure that
you can apply the same model of export
lead industrialization that applied to
China I don't think you can battle this
for your future groups in additional
challenges that that many countries are
confronted with new technologies and
there is a general fear that robots are
going to make low wage labor in
developing countries redundant so
remember one of the big advantages of
developing countries has always been
that they can offer they can the
low-wage labor if low wage labor becomes
less important because firms can rely on
machines then developing countries are
going to lose this this disadvantage
they have had that said I have to say
that so far we have not seen any
evidence of either so this is based
actually on from some work we did in the
workmen last year in the context of the
World Development Report and let me just
show you this graph that contradicts
what I just said actually so what this
graph shows is that and again it's a
it's a correlation for the most part the
horizontal axis you have industries
ordered according to the right intensity
of using robots so for example here the
automobile industry uses robots very
intensively followed by rubber and
plastics metal and so on
and so what we found is that those
industries that use robots very
intensive
are actually the industries that also
experience the fastest growth of imports
from developing countries and these
imports are inputs in intermediate
product and part and essentially the
story behind this is that by using robot
you increase productivity and as firms
become more productive and grow they
need more intermediate parts more lay
more more components and this they still
get from developing countries so that's
why I said this fear that that robots
will render trade with developing
countries redundant has not materialized
yet but it's still a fear that remains
in the horizon because so far robots
have not been applied in developing
countries themselves so of course the
problem becomes if you if in developing
countries you can use robots to produce
the parts of the components then
eventually jobs in these countries are
going to be threatened as well so so we
have not seen that yet but it's still a
fear that's out there so that creates
create this need for the new vision that
that I spoke of so this is something
that one is immediately confronted with
if one joins an organization like the
World Bank these days and again to
summarize the main point there are two
main challenges that countries face so
developing countries poor countries
faced one is there is this backlash
against free trade in developed
countries to put it bluntly many
developed countries are closing their
borders so if you are a poor country you
cannot really count on your exports to
be welcomed in in richer countries and
at the same time there is a fear of
automation that may render low-wage jobs
redundant and on top of that I would say
there is also a lot of competition among
developing countries so if you are you
know in Kenya and you try to to get into
the export market into the US export
market you face competition from
Ethiopia you face competition from
Bangladesh from Vietnam it's a very
competitive space at this point so
against this is background this old
model of development so what's the old
model export-led industrialization so
what seems to have worked for China or
Korea or Vietnam is questionable and and
that raises the question what is the
alternative so if this is not going to
work what what is likely to work for
countries so let me you know now come
into some of the alternatives that are
being proposed in the development world
so the first one is what people call
leap frogging into services and the idea
is there is to leap directly from
agriculture to the service sector so by
passing this stage of manufacturing so
the problem with this is so far I have
not seen you know and we goes
theoretical frame ordered by theoretical
I don't necessarily mean many equations
but some conceptual framework that
clarifies how exactly this is supposed
to to work on the empirical side there
are many challenges if you think about
how this model may work so for one
services is a very broad and
heterogeneous category so when we talk
about services we talked about Tories
but we also talked about financial and
business services you may talk about
driving a car or being a hairdresser or
you may talk about being a lawyer or an
accountant so it's a very heterogeneous
category
in addition so far there has been no
evidence of leapfrogging
in any country and again there I'm going
to rely on them on the world Development
Report of 2020 and that was actually one
of the interesting takeaways from this
report and let me show you what this
graph shows because I think it's one of
the most interesting graphs in this
report so what this graph shows is how
fast countries grow once they join
one-third sectors joined global value
chains and they can join global value
chains in various ways so you can join
by participating what what we call
limited manufacturing so limited
manufacturing is producing products that
require low skill and low wages
so like textile
choose the kind of products that still
you know Vietnam or Ethiopia produce
then you know in blue you can have
countries participating by joining
advanced manufacturing and services and
by advanced manufacturing we mean cars
so automobiles machinery chemicals so
products that require more educated more
educated labor force and more capital
then you know in purple you have
innovative in red you have innovative
activities and these are the kind of
activities that the more advanced the
richest countries participate with
participate in so this include any
product that or services that require a
highly skilled labor force and they also
include mostly services so they include
mostly things like design and research
and so on so you can see you know how
fast countries grow once they join this
global value chains in one of these
forms and so the fastest growth is seen
when grown countries join through
limited manufacturing so that says that
from the time they join here zero twenty
years later they have grouped the per
capita income this is all per capita has
grown cumulatively by 57 percent so this
is a huge number so this essentially the
story of Vietnam then you know if you're
in blue it shows what happens if you
join through advanced manufacturing and
again you grow very fast but a little at
a lower pace by 48 percent and in the
last case you grow by the 32 percent and
again this is what you would expect
because countries would join here you
know the red part these are countries
that are already rich so it's harder to
as you become richer and richer it's
harder to grow fast so it makes sense
that these numbers are lower but and
another thing to point out about this
graph is countries can be present in in
only three graphs why because they may
move from one to another
so for example one example is Korea
Korea South Korea started here
Green part and eventually moved the blue
part by participating more advanced
manufacturing cars and so on and by now
it's in the red part
okay so country's transition across the
three parts so when I show this graph
the many people asked immediately the
question so do we see countries
leapfrogging so go directly from being
an agricultural country leapfrogging
directly to the red part and this is if
you're in the World Bank for many people
this is the vision for the future that
you're in Africa you know you are your
cameo your Ethiopia and rather than
industrializing and getting to the green
part we are going to jump right into the
red part right and and the fact is that
we don't have a single case a single
country called we've seen that in the
past so of course the fact that this
hasn't happened in the past doesn't mean
it cannot happen in the future but the
fact is we've never seen it so the more
successful example is Korea and Korea
spend again time in all three parts but
it's been very little time with the
green part so very few years in limited
manufacturing and eventually it jumped
to advanced manufacturing but we don't
see in the data we've never seen a case
where a country managed to go directly
from being an agricultural in agrarian
and agrarian setting to to going to to
being an advanced economy specializing
in services and innovative activities so
I'm not again I don't want to say that
this cannot happen but but we don't have
any evidence and we don't have any
theory to support this so far the second
you know view that you often hear about
is urbanization and again development
has often because traditionally been
[Music]
traditionally gone hand in hand with
urbanization and we do see increase in
an organization in many developing
countries so even in Africa we see the
emergence of big cities however again
the evidence here suggests that again
I'll to borrow a term from a paper by
calling done bowling fools here and Jade
WAP and Polaroid in many cases what we
see in Africa is urban
without industrialization and when we
see that in cities in Africa then we
don't we find that the emergence of the
cities is not associated with any good
development outcomes so what they show
in this paper by calling at all is that
the cities they are large but the the
poverty rates are still highly
educational levels are high and any
measure you use and a traditional
measure of development or well-being by
any measure the cities are not doing
very well and one point they make in
this paper is there is a difference
between what they call consumption and
production cities and consumption cities
our cities associated with higher
poverty consumption cities are cities
where there is there are a lot of
services but these are consumption
services so you have many hairdressers
and drivers in the end you have many
people working with these professions
that are classified as services but they
don't seem to be contributing to poverty
reduction and this is to be to be
contrasted with the so called production
services that are associated with trade
that tend to be associated with better
development outcome so the point I'm
making this paper is that somehow in
Africa cities cannot play this role of
being engines of development partly
because they concentrate on these
consumption services so now I want maybe
to come to the third to the third type
hypothesis to the third view that I
think deserves further exploration and
this relates to the following intuitive
idea that if international trade is not
going to be the engine of growth in the
future simply because of the political
reality then perhaps the domestic market
will be asked to play a more important
role and there I would like to start
with some some casual observation so one
observation is that India has been
growing fast we don't know how fast
because of of all the issues with the
data no one knows exactly what the
numbers are but but
I think that I think we it's safe to say
is that growth in India has not been
driven by trade for sure now it is a
very large country so it's a country
where the large domestic market could
potentially support growth why because
you know a large economy can can support
internal economies of scale a
counterexample is Nigeria so Nigeria is
also a large country notice largest
India but it's a it's a it's a large
country is very rich in natural
resources it's it's reaching people it
has a large population and it has had
periods of fast growth mainly on oil
prices go up but there has been no
sustained development and no poverty
reduction and so if you if you contrast
these examples one one striking
difference between the two is that is
the degree of inequality and this is not
to say that India is an equal economy
not at all but but Nigeria is well known
for the high degree of inequalities
essentially wealth is concentrated in
the hands of very few and so when there
is a positive shock for example high oil
prices that translate to fast aggregate
growth this growth never trickles down
or it reaches down in the form that
Golan and toiled describes so you have
some some rich you have a very small
rich class they they become richer
because oil prices are high they build
nice homes they need construction
workers they need drivers they need
hairdressers they need housekeepers
these services increase these are
consumption services so you have
aggregate growth but you don't have
sustained poverty reduction right so in
this so that leads to that to these
additional hypothesis that perhaps this
high inequality is actually a constraint
to growth and poverty reduction and and
in cases like Nigeria or Angola
there are cases where that exemplify
this it is it's the story so you know I
try to explain
or using one or two examples but of
course these are one or two examples and
so one question is how do we
operationalize this idea and what
exactly does it mean to say we have a
large market and what's the meaning of
equality in this context you know how
equal is an equal what exactly is
development and how large does a market
need to be in order for these mechanisms
to be real relevant and last but not
least so I gave the example of India but
if a country is not India if the country
is small what are you supposed to do
this is not going to be you know I'm not
going to make the case here for
countries trying to expand through war
to create Lebensraum so so but but my
point is that one needs a conceptual
framework to think about these issues
and that actually brings me to some to
some work the paper I've been working on
recently and that perhaps is you know a
good way to structure this talk in the
sense that I'm transy transitioning from
either talked like myself from what I've
done in the World Bank to the more
academic work and you know I just like I
just want to give you an idea so far
what the motivation for this academic
work was so this is by the way this is a
joint project with with trees twisting
green who's here he said the World Bank
and we have a preliminary draft out and
you know the idea behind that this paper
is inspired by an old paper by were fish
life or invasion from 89 but that's
actually a paper that makes the case for
the importance of the domestic market
and a certain degree of equality and so
this is not their famous paper on the
big push in the Jaypee this is an
earlier paper and that paper itself
formalized some of the ideas that have
been in development for a very long time
before so most importantly by Arthur
Lewis but also you know by Gustav Brown
is here and other people and I don't
want to try to cover all of them because
I'm sure I will forget many but but the
point is that these ideas were out in
development for a very long time and the
paper by by Murphy Hall actually
formalize these ideas and you know this
paper gives rise to an empirical
threshold crossing model that that we
estimate in the using a methodology very
much in the spirit of present and in
Tracy's other famous paper in the Jaypee
the entry paper so we we estimate this
model using final data from multiple
countries and we use it to calculate you
know among various other things how
large a market needs to be in order to
to rely on itself you know to benefit
from domestic economies of scale without
relying on trade so let me deal with the
remaining time which is not much let me
outline what this theoretical framework
looks like I'm not going to show any
questions here but I'll give you another
general idea it's a highly stylized
model but I just want to to convey the
main idea so imagine you have a closed
economy and this is this can be relaxed
but the closed economy case is here
relevant because I'm going to focus
precisely on the case where trade is not
important anymore imagine you have to
sexual sectors agriculture in
manufacturing what are what are the
preferences look like there is an
agricultural good food and this is a
necessity the consumer spent all their
income on food until they receive a
minimal subsistence level this is called
Z for income levels above Z consumers
can afford to buy manufactures it's
assumed that there is a well-defined
ordering of goods in terms of
desirability so once you are above the
subsistence level if you start buying
some goods and then as you become richer
buy goods of higher desirability and so
as consumption increases what in this
model is highly stylized model what
increases is not the quantity of the
goods you consumed what increases is the
variety of goods you control the range
of goods in terms of technology there
are two inputs land and labor land is a
fixed factor so as a result there are
decreasing returns to scale in
agriculture and then in manufacturing
that's important there are two
technologies there is a constant return
to take to scale technology
that has no fixed costs and there is
also an increasing returns to scale
technology that has fixed costs but
lowering variable costs so firms have a
choice they can if they want us to
produce manufactured goods they can
produce using the constant returns to
scale technology or they can use the IRS
increasing returns to scale technology
and industrialization in this setup is
defined as the transition from the
constant returns to scale to the IRS
technology the market structure is as
follows in agriculture you have perfect
competition in manufacturing if you
produce with a backstop technology there
is perfect competition but if you are in
manufacturing and you produce with the
IRS technology so if you are
industrialized then there are monopolies
there is a monopoly there are monopoly
rents and the monopoly rents actually
play an important role in this model and
finally and that's important that that's
the appealing feature of this model it's
assumed that there is poverty and
inequality to start with poverty here is
defined as follows the wage there is
only one wage in the in the economy the
wage in agriculture is the same as in
manufacturing and this wage is below the
subsistence level so if all you do is
being a worker in agriculture then you
kind of by manufacturers and you're poor
you don't have enough to eat on the
other hand and there's also a very high
degree of inequality in the sense that
most people are laborers so they rely
only on the labor income in their poor
however there is also a fraction in this
population that owns land rents and and
shares and so this is you know the
structure and then what they show is
that in that you know with these
assumptions you can have an equilibrium
and it's actually unique ok Librium with
industrialization and in this a [ __ ]
bloomed you have the monopolist they
show that the monopolist will adopt the
IRS technology when when the variable
costs when the profits are positive and
that means that the variable profits are
high enough to cover the fixed costs so
in the marginal sector of the economy
the variable profits are going to be
equal to the fixed cost so this is
exactly what gives rise to this
break-even condition and for those of
you familiar with a model you see now
that you know why I say this is very
similar to the said set up in President
and injuries in Bresnahan injuries they
estimate threshold market threshold
sizes for for a duopoly to enter for
more firms to enter a market here we
don't do that but here which simply ask
the question how large does a market
need to be for the monopolist to to view
this IRS technology as desirable so to
switch from the CRS to the IRS
technology now variable prophets
themselves depend on sales so sales have
to be large enough to to cover the fixed
costs so denote by n star the minimum
efficient scale then the cells are going
to depend on two things in the setup
they're going to depend on the size of
the domestic market and so that's why a
large domestic market is going to help
but they also depend on the size of the
middle class and so now introduce
another term here middle class what's
the middle class in this model so middle
class is the number of consumers who are
not very poor so they have enough money
to buy manufactures but they are not so
rich that they buy only a few luxury
goods that you can actually produce with
these packs of technology so there are
actually the consumers that have incomes
between the subsistence level and
between the minimum efficient scale okay
so in other words what happens in this
economy is if you are really poor if
you're if you rely on your your wage
that's below the subsistence level then
you just buy food nothing else if if you
have some shares in inland and or you
know in industry with industrialization
then you can buy you use your first Z
units of your income to buy food once
you've reached the subsistence level you
use the next income to buy
industrialized goods so goods that that
are produced at mass scale and then you
know if you have even more money if
you're in the upper
if you're truly rich that's the upper
class then you buy food you buy these
goods that are mass-produced the goods
that are also bought by the middle-class
but you also buy the box top you're so
buy the luxury goods that are produced
with the constant returns to scale
technology so I think this model has in
my view it's very simple very stylized
but it has a number of very attractive
features because you can use it to
explain what's happening in many
developing countries so if you think
about Nigeria the example I gave you
before so this is a case where the
middle class is relatively small so you
get you know that you have resources but
you have the very poor buying just food
and then you have the very rich buying
just luxury goods so goods that you
don't produce they are not mass-produced
with a IRS technology and you know in
these cases you end up with these
consumption services and growth that
doesn't trickle down so I think it's
very much you can use that to explain
what happens in many developing
countries now what are the implications
for development you cannot you can you
you can you can apply this model to to
tell a story about structure and
transformation that looks as follows so
a poor country take again the example I
gave you on Nigeria needs an initial
boost so you need something that it's
going to create resources a wealth
effect and this can be an increase in
agricultural productivity this is again
something that the early development
literature often emphasized that you
need agricultural productivity to
increase otherwise you don't have you
cannot have enough resources free from
agriculture to go to manufacturing but
alternatively you can also have exports
of natural resources for example in the
case of Nigeria you can have oil and
that's where the model becomes a little
more allows for a little openness in the
sense that in order to export oil you
need to be you need to be trading with
another country but here trade in that
case has a very specific function it's
not it's not a case where you you use
trade to tap into foreign markets and
exploit economies of scale you just used
to generate this initial wealth effect
no - just bring revenue into the country
and this is the only function that these
oil revenues have okay so you have this
wealth effect and this wealth effect can
jump-start a process of structural
transformation how also take the case of
agricultural productivity increasing
then the wages rise both because
productivity increases and because there
is more demand for labour in agriculture
then the rents rise and labor move from
agricultural to manufacturing as
manufacturing expands agricultural sinks
shrink so this is the process of
industrialization and so the main
insights of this model is that what you
need for for industrialization to happen
is you need this initial boost so this
can be as I said that the cultural
productivity or initial growth in
exports you need to have a large
domestic market and you also need a
certain degree of equality and here
equality is interpreted in a very
specific way what you need is is a
middle class you need people with a
purchasing with enough purchasing power
that are going to support support
producing products at mass scale and
taking it to a car and taking advantage
of increasing returns to scale okay so
one question you may have is so here
industrialization and development are
synonyms in this model and one question
is quite as this lead to poverty
reduction which is what I'm interested
in so directly there is an effect
because in a model of wages increase
that as wages increase eventually the
living standards of the poor improve and
they may rise above poverty in a
different profit increase and so the the
living standards of the small
shareholders to the extent of the small
shareholders may be below the poverty
line also improve but they're also
regions that are outside the model so
for example the memory technological
spillover is associated with
industrialization so these are not in
the model but in other literature
they've been shown to be very important
for growth and empirically you know
industrialization has always been a
source
development so you can rely on this
empirical observation so this is sort of
the theoretical background of the model
and so this theory structure leads to
leads to a threshold crossing more than
that looks as follows that's very simple
the profit in the increasing return to
sector sector are given as follows there
the market size times per capita
variable profit so these are the
variable profit minus fixed costs so
following a game that's the part that's
inspired by present and increase the
advance the beauty of present and
injuries is they could estimate an entry
model without using data on prices which
are very hard to get of course you know
I know Steve is going to say this is a
huge you know huge weakness of this
literature and I agree but if you are
trying to think about poverty here for
100 countries this this becomes an
advantage because you can try to relay
all these entities I talked about
variable profits or or fixed cost to
observe a plus rather than to market
observables prices so we model here
market size as a function of observables
and similarly variable profit as a
function of demand observables and cost
demand variables and cost variables and
same thing with fixed costs and a firm
is going to enter the IRS sector so it's
going to adopt this new technology if
the variable profit exceed the fixed
costs and so that gives right so let me
now come to to the part that that makes
a direct connection to the empirics as I
said we model all these things variable
profits or fixed costs as functions of
observables and these observers are as
follows so in terms of market size so we
define market size as a function of the
following variables so the population of
the country in terms of row bodies and
in particular in this specification is
how many people are people who don't
have the purchasing power of the
middle-class then the market size also
depends on the share of the middle-class
and that will I will tell you in a
moment how we define that and in
addition we take into account the fact
that if you actually take this model to
the data in reality most countries are
not closed right in the model I
presented we we started with a stylized
case of a closed economy but actually
most countries are open to trade so then
to take that into account we define two
measures of integration one is based on
summing up the populations of all
countries with which particular
countries integrated with and the other
one is based on the summing up all the
incomes of the countries with with which
a country is integrated with so that's
actually I think one of the biggest
contributions of these of this work that
the way we define integration so in
order to see which countries are
integrated with others we exploited
information on participation in the
World Trade Organization god but also
many regional trade agreements and we
relied we relied on some port by other
authors that actually went down all the
original trade agreements and go down
the legal provisions in each case in
which case there were legal provisions
that connected countries so if there is
a legal provision connecting two
countries then we assign an indicator
equal to one and then we use that to
form weights summing up all the
countries so then the main I will try to
avoid getting into the details given
time constraints but the main point I
want to make here is that we end up
using two different measures of
international integration and one based
is based on the idea that when you
connect with other countries you may
good connect with other countries that
are very large in population so then
this way you get access to a lot of
consumers but there is an also an
alternative measure
that relies on the notion that you
connect with countries that may be very
rich they may have high income and this
is also valuable because you may connect
to countries that are small in terms of
population but they are very that they
have large purchasing power so in terms
of that very per capita variable profits
there again we the choice of variables
is very much informed by the model in
the sense that we use past export growth
and also past agricultural productivity
growth as observables that may lead to
higher variable profits and finally when
it comes to the fixed costs that's when
we rely on the very large literature own
institutional institutions in developing
countries which suggests that variables
such as the tropical climate a desert
climate distance to the coast ruggedness
and also legal origins whether there are
British legal origins of French legal
origins have an impact to to how well a
country is run which in turn may have
effects on the size of the fixed costs
so these are the observables we use in
the game there you can think of many
robustness checks and many alternative
definitions the dependent variable we
use in this work is is sustained poverty
reduction and so this is so in other
words the question we are asking is can
we relay sustained poverty reduction to
industrialization and if so how large
doesn't market me to be for this process
to be relevant so in order to do that we
need the final we need to define what
sustained poverty reduction is and
without again going into the details
I'll just give you a brief overview we
use the protocol net this is a
computational tool developed by the
World Bank that allows you to compute to
compute poverty rates for many different
countries we use that to compute poverty
four particular years and then in some
cases we have to interpolate given
missing data and then we break up our
data into five year periods and then we
look we look at whether poverty has
declined in every single year in this
five year period
so if poverty has declined in every year
in five year period then for this period
we assign a variable equal to one to
saying that during that period we had
sustained poverty reduction right if
poverty declines in the first two years
and then goes up in the next year then
we assign we assign a value equal to
zero to this measure of sustained
poverty reduction so in other words what
we try to do and again there are many
different ways to do that but one has to
start somewhere is to say do we see
countries reducing poverty over a period
of time every single year if so then we
call that sustained poverty reduction
okay so this is going to be our
dependent variable so let me show you
you know you know some patterns in the
data that I think quite interesting so
we have a total of 93 countries so we
exclude countries that have already
eliminated poverty so these are the
advanced countries or all countries that
have poverty rates below three percent
and again poverty is defined in terms of
extreme poverty so being below the 1.9
threshold and what this graph what this
table shows you is how sustained real
per capita GDP growth relate to
sustained extreme poverty reduction so
what we did for poverty you can also
look for growth for per capita grown
income growth you can take per capita
income growth and see if it if it if it
you know if there is growth every single
period then you will call it sustained
sustained per capita income growth so as
you would expect growth and poverty
reduction are highly correlated and this
is a point that people have often made
growth is important for poverty this is
undeniable so 76 percent you know if we
see poverty reduction in 76 percent of
the cases
this is also accompanied by growth
however there are also many cases or 82
in particular out of the 347 where you
do have growth but you don't see poverty
reduction so growth doesn't
automatically generate poverty reduction
and we see these these are all cases in
countries that are extremely unequal
so again Nigeria comes to mind these are
cases where you may have very fast
growth usually fueled by by commodity
prices
but then this growth never trickles down
and so this is the first thing to show
the second thing is again showing the
data on sustained extreme poverty
reduction so here what we graphed is how
many cases of sustained poverty
reduction till you come over time in
various parts of the world and the first
thing that jumps out if you look at this
graph is how high the percentages
associated with sustained poverty
reduction are so most of the numbers are
well above 50% so many countries in 86%
of these country 5-year pairs you she
sustained poverty reduction and again
this speaks to the fact that there has
been enormous progress made so we do see
poverty reduction over time our data by
the way are from 1950 there are some
other things that I think are quite
interesting if you look at the period
2006 to 2010 so this is post financial
crisis this is still a period where
poverty goes down very fast in many
parts of the world and that that again
shows that advanced countries and
developing countries are not not always
synchronized so even though that the
advanced countries the industrialized
world was in a major crisis they were
still progress made in many developing
countries some cases that really stand
out is Africa you know again sub-saharan
Africa until 96 you have hardly any
poverty reduction and again this is well
known in other cases Latin America which
is more puzzling and we think that has
more
with the data let me also show you some
patterns on international integration
that I think are quite interesting as I
mentioned there are two measures of
international integration one captures
the size of a of the international
market the integrated market as measured
by population and the other one as
measured by income and by relative
income and so what we do here is
actually we construct a variable that
measures integration in relative terms
so what's the size of the market in
terms of population that you connect
with relative to your own market these
are all so one thing you see is starting
in 2000 around 2000 in almost our world
the the integrated market jumps up right
so in terms of population countries are
connecting to much larger market so
what's going on here is very very simply
this is China connect to China you
connect to a very larger market but at
the same time see what happens you know
if you define this integration measure
in terms of income then you know it goes
down in the game that's a graphical way
of portraying the entry of China this is
another you know way to see that very
clearly again in 2001 this is just four
countries that are members of the World
Trade Organization so in 2001 in terms
of population you know that there is a
jump you know it seems that countries
are connecting the relative integrated
market in terms of population becomes
much larger than before because China
enters the World Trade Organization but
in terms of income you have this huge
jump
but then the income in China rises and
so then again the relative income rises
so this is you know one way of
portraying what has happened but at the
same time you know you can also see what
the concern is so if you're a developing
country you connect with China you know
all of a sudden you are connecting with
a competitor rather than a country to
which you can send your exports so there
is another thing this is important is
when you when we I'll skip that
because there's no time left but I'll
tell you very briefly what what
eventually our empirical results show
the empirical results show that the
market size is very important for
explaining poverty reduction and market
size as I said is defined by three
variables so the population the total
population is important international
integration is important and when we
look at international integration
actually what's most important is how
rich the country to connect with our so
you know connecting to countries with
higher relative income is extremely it's
much more variable than connecting to
countries with large populations that's
what the results suggest so just you
know to give you some numbers
if you connect with a country that has
the same relative population as you do
on average it's like adding one hundred
sixty thousand people to your country if
you are if you connect with a country
that has the same relative income as you
do then it's like connect it's like
adding 20 million people to your
population so so the income the relative
income is much more important and
discussed direct implication so to give
you an example Kenya is a country that
right now is considering should we
engage in a bilateral agreement with a
united the United States or shall we be
focused more in a pan-african trade
agreement and if you take these results
they saturate it's much more valuable
for Kenya to connect to the United
States which is a rich economy rather
than relying on the African market again
this is not surprising this is what
Korea didn't this is what China did and
this is what the results of the model
also say actually in quantitative terms
they suggest huge effects now of course
the problem is that it's not clear that
all these countries can't connect to the
United States anymore right so so what
we are saying is if you cannot connect
to the United States
maybe the alternative is to connect to
your neighbors that may not be as rich
but they have a very large population
and this is not as valuable but it's
still valuable compared to the
alternative of being completely closed
so you can take these results as giving
you some sense of how important regional
integration may be in that in that
setting
but finally I want to stop with that
because this is more in the spirit in
the spirit of of Goods Nets finally we
consider one counterfactual which is the
strongest one where we say you know
suppose there is no integration at all
so not only can't you connect with the
United States but you cannot even
connect with your neighbors and this is
not so far-fetched because many
developing countries do they the
neighbors as as big competitor so they
are not willing to engage in trade
cooperation and so if you just rely on
the domestic market how large does this
domestic market have to be so that you
can have sustained poverty reduction and
so the number we get out of a model this
is the threshold is 328 million so these
are 320 28 million in raw bodies so
people that are below the middle class
okay so think of those has been 328
million to people so the only country
that meets this criterion is India right
there is no one else and this is you
know something that actually the graph
shows now now the reason this is not so
bleak is the you know if you don't have
328 million raw bodies you can still
meet this threshold by increasing by
halle middle class by increasing the
purchasing power of the people within
your country so this is one way of
transforming you know a row body to
someone who can actually consume more
and so again to give you a specific
example take the case of Norway Norway
found oil in the late 1960s at that
point on ready Norway was a fairly equal
society it's a very small country it's
not a country that has relied on trade
to grow and it's but it's a country it's
not a country that has a very large
domestic market it's not a country that
has a very large population but it's a
country that has that has always had a
very high degree of equal
so I forget what the exact population of
Norway is it's certainly not 300 million
but if you actually if you if you
according to our estimates if you go
from zero percentage middle class to
100% middle class in your your in the
average country this is like adding 540
million people so if your middle class
increases by 10% then it's like adding
50 for poor people in the country so so
ultimately what they suggest is that if
we end up in a world where we have much
less trade and much less regional
integration so we open trade it's still
going to be you know the first choice
it's extremely important for developing
countries and the smaller the country
the more important it is but if that's
not an option if you have to rely more
on the domestic market what are the
options not to have war in order to you
know to raise enlarge your country you
may argue some might argue you may want
higher fertility to increase your your
population this would be a very perverse
way to justify all this sometimes we
have this policy that try to actually
increase population tanzania is one
example where there is a very strong
policy on the current head of the state
is encouraging people who have more kids
but of course creates all kinds of other
problems so if you're not going to
advocate any of these then an
alternative is to try to create a more
equal society with larger middle class
because by adding middle class you are
you add purchasing power and and again
this is not something new here many
people have made the point before that
the middle class may be important but
here you know using this framework we
can actually quantify how important
disease and finally how do you create a
middle class so again in this model that
we have there is a very direct mapping
between the the theoretical structure
and the policy implication which is the
way you create it is to sort
by taxing income but more importantly by
a more equitable distribution of shares
so it actually it's an argument in for
in favor of wealth redistribution more
than income redistribution and and I
will stop here but I want to make sure
that this last comment is not
interpreted as advocacy for the wealth
tax I want to make clear that this is an
argument that I think may be very
relevant in very poor countries
countries like Angola or Nigeria where
you have a very large share of the
population owning next to nothing and in
this country is a certain degree of
redistribution from the rich to the
middle class but also to the poor may
ultimately be a precondition for growth
rather than an impediment growth so I
will stop here and thank you very much
for your patience
[Applause]
thank you very much for this diverse and
insightful lecture I have two questions
but feel free to shorten if you want to
take more one is that in the beginning
you said trade helped growth in Asia
very much but not so much in sub-saharan
Africa and I was interested in what you
think are the most convincing
explanations for for that phenomenon and
secondly when we argue that we should
invest in a global middle class how do
you think well that might that be an
issue with current debates on the limits
to that sort of consumption globally
with regards to environmental concerns I
think I'll take three questions welcome
back thank you for being with us I just
had a question you were speaking about
elephant curves dragon curves you know
more inequality but also there's been
very much you know much lower confidence
in the Bretton with institutions and my
question is referring to the understand
at all paper which was published on the
World Bank website ten days ago and
speaking about this whole idea foreign
aid capture my question to you is what
do you think about that paper I thought
it was stunning that you know showed all
those correlations between you know
World Bank
you know dispersions and the higher
levels of offshore capital accounts by
like seven and a half percent what's
your view towards that I also totally
understand that if your hand is tied for
the next 72 hours thank you
okay let me answer these questions at
this if there are more so regarding the
role of trade Africa has not traded much
with the rest of the world the way East
Asia had so it's not that Trey did not
help Africa is that trade has not
happened in Africa the way it has
happened in East Asia to the extent that
trade has been present in Africa for the
most part it has been in the form of
commodity exports and I think that that
is very the story there is very
consistent with a one I just presented
namely you have commodity exports they
generate export revenue but the growth
these export revenues create never
trickles down and it doesn't written
down because it stays in the hand so
very few but certainly that the story
that you hear for Nigeria or Angola but
many other countries that it's not grow
that trickles down in in Asia it was a
very different story
where trade not only took advantage of
the low-wage labor in China or Korea or
Taiwan and they of course also took
advantage of the rich markets in in the
United States and Europe but in addition
to that the resources they amassed
through trade who exports were invested
very different Linux countries that were
investing to fund infrastructure
substantial physical infrastructure but
also human capital infrastructure so
they did make this investments that were
very important for growth and ultimately
poverty reduction so the developing
experiences of the two parts of the
world were very very different I'm sorry
the second question was for consumption
that's a good question I mean they are
telling my view so whenever one talks
about trade Lee states and especially
you know trade as as it relates to the
middle class in the consumption of the
middle class there is an immediately
push back because
if developing countries grow the same
way that developed countries come grow
the path this is going to put a lot of
pressure on the environment and that's
for sure mm these first you know if you
actually look at where the most of the
pollution is its concentrated on some
very large developing countries mostly
China and India so one could gain a lot
of one could make great progress in
addressing this issue it's just by
focusing on these two countries in China
is by no means it's not a developed
country but it's by no means a poor
country that cannot make a serious
effort in addressing these issues I
think when it comes to countries in
sub-saharan Africa so countries like you
know still tenure at COP or Molly or
child countries whether the poverty
rates are extremely high still where you
have 30 percent of the population living
under the poverty rate or you have a
country like knee-jerk where you have
the median age of the population is 15
years 15 years imagine what this means
then in my view climate change is not a
priority in this country so when you go
there and you say you know developing a
middle class or growth or or trade you
it's not that important you should have
second thoughts about all this because
it's part for the environment I mean not
only do I think this is not effective I
think it's immoral for for us to be
saying that to these countries when we
don't do our part so I think we should
start you know with with with of course
the advanced economies are to the extent
you go to developing countries China and
India before we go to sub-saharan Africa
and talk about about climate change
there regarding the elite cultural paper
so I don't want to talk about these
papers simply because this is not the
topic of the Kootenays lecture I mean
institutions are important for
development that's for sure and you know
in the frame of a just show you
institutions are indirectly measured by
the fixed costs and we do find that they
play a very important role in
development I mean one issue that not
just the World Bank the development
because always face he's going to comes
to development everyone always says
institutions are important you can't
make progress unless you fix the
institutions but no one has a recipe
what is the right policy what is what in
how do you do better I think what
research has shown that perhaps only
constructive inside in that regard is
the only thing that helps is
transparency you know I do think that
the world bank should follow the same
policies eat it advises other countries
to follow name they'll be completely
transparent
you know regarding this paper I mean I
just make one comment if you actually
look at the aid affected by your list
it's a very small percentage it's a
seven percent so you know whatever the
paper is I don't think it speaks to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you